no tengo muchos recuerdos de la infancia
pero recuerdo algo en particular
recuerdo que mi mano derecha tenía un
sartén de metal en el centro una vasija
de plástico y en mi lado izquierdo tenía
una más pequeña de metal
en mi mano derecha tenía
tenía una cuchara de madera y el metal
aluminio según yo que jugaba a tocar la
batería es algo muy dinámico muy
interesante para mí según yo que quedaba
triste de bronco pero lamentablemente no
quería hacerlo
de hecho muchos de nosotros vemos esos
mismos niños hoy en día vemos este
ningún patrón somos curiosos y garra más
cosas y jugamos con ellos
también recuerdan el kinder agarraba un
color agarra otro color y según yo
jugaba más colores resiente un picasso
cuando era chiquito y pensaba que hacer
un artista
ahorita vas a tocar ningún instrumento y
no sé pintar soy de lo peor de ellos es
mi nivel de primaria
pero cuando recuerdo lo que pasó antes
cuando era un pequeño me di cuenta de
que todos nos comportamos de la misma
manera
tal vez si recuerdan ustedes pondrán
pequeños van a ser una relación de hecho
así vemos a los niños hoy en día también
lo hacen para esa manera también pintan
también colorean y también agarran
sartenes para tocar la batería como
droga
tenemos teorías hacemos investigación
realizamos experimentos y al final
concluimos de un color será mejor o con
cuál muchas gracias suena confort para
tocar la material
de hecho esos dos pasos a un científico
un ingeniero
tiene teorías hacen experimentos
realizan investigación y después de las
conclusiones igual ellos no van a
determinar cuál será mejor para tocar la
tecla batería pero ese es el proceso
pensando acerca de eso me di cuenta
porque no todos somos científicos porque
no todos somos ingenieros
y creo que tengo esto
nosotros como adultos paramos en demasía
lo que le ofrece a los niños
siempre cuando hacen algo que esperan
para nosotros los páramos
imaginen que van al centro comercial más
supermercado de la mano y nos permite y
le comentaron hoy no va a soltar pero no
corras ok
es lo que hacemos todos nosotros
en ese momento el que sale corriendo y
pasa lo que no queremos que pasara
otro otro caso puede ser cuando nos
saltamos en el parque no te vas a ir
para allá porque atrás social o no
agarra el control de la tele porque lo
haces configurar donde me vas a sartén
porque me lo vas a quebrar
o de hecho está tocando la batería como
yo lo hice y le decimos que pare
los niños tienen muchas preguntas
por ejemplo porque el cielo azul o
porque los pájaros vuelan o porque la
naranja sea diferente a limón o porque
son las cosas como son
siempre es tan curioso acerca de lo que
pasa alrededor
lamentablemente nosotros nunca tenemos
la respuesta correcta siempre decimos es
unas cosas porque yo lo digo simplemente
decimos ya deja de preguntar
recuerdo en la primaria una experiencia
muy particular recuerdo que cuando
estaba en la primaria yo pregunté por
qué vamos a hacer la la tabla de
multiplicar en qué momento vamos a
empezar a multiplicar la vida rutina
disparando pero no pierde la respuesta
y mi maestro tampoco la respuesta fue
porque yo soy la maestra porque llamando
aquí o simplemente porque tenés que
pasar haciendo escolar
nunca tenemos una respuesta concreta
samuel johnson dijo la curiosidad es la
primera pasión y la última
en la secundaria recuerdo en la clase de
física todo el mundo pasa por la misma
situación
tenemos que aprender las ecuaciones
super sencillas por si igual la masa por
aceleración
eran las situaciones más simples del
mundo pero en la escuela en mi clase
recuerdo muy particular pues en tanta
desesperación del profe que no
entendíamos que recuerdo una frase que
se quedó hasta
recuerdo de esto
todo es un carnet de maquila es el regla
cuando me dijo la frase todo es un carné
de maquilar siente una puñalada en el
corazón y el pensamiento se vinieron
obviamente y sinceramente pensé que
nunca iba a llegar a pasar a siete años
fue tanta la repetición de la frase son
carne de maquilar que para muchos de
nosotros se convierte en realidad
sin embargo yo no tenía preguntas quería
saber cómo los automóviles funcionaban
como los aviones volaban como pudiéramos
explorar otros planetas o incluso qué
pasaría si todos saltamos en un tiempo
son preguntas que no tienen respuesta
pero aunque no sabe la respuesta yo era
curioso
fue tanta mi curiosidad acerca de la
velocidad que en vez de hacer una poca
investigación
hay dos pilares básicos en
el rendimiento escolar
esto fue determinado por un grupo de
científicos del reino unido que
determinaron que el conocimiento general
y la disciplina son base para el éxito
en el aspecto académico
no obstante estos mismos científicos
tendrán un tercer pilar que la
curiosidad
todos sabemos que el conocimiento
general es base de hecho es determinado
por el examen de wonder link que es un
examen de 12 preguntas y que termina qué
tan rápido puedes preguntar este tipo de
preguntas el segundo la disciplina con
esmero es base para cualquier parte del
éxito lo necesitamos
por otro lado la curiosidad también
tanto como milán
estos científicos determinaron que hay
cinco factores por los cuales nosotros
podemos determinar nuestro éxito en la
en la escuela
inteligente general desempeño académico
responsabilidad apertura nuevas
experiencias
este expediente lector típico
este tipo este estas cinco variables
determinado cuál va a ser nuestro
nuestro nuestros logros
sin embargo hay una relación muy fuerte
todas están relacionadas pero como
podemos ver la apertura de nuevas
experiencias
en ese sentido intelectual típico son
muy fuertes tiene una relación muy muy
fuerte
y que es la apertura en las experiencias
es una idea la curiosidad esa curiosidad
seguir aprendiendo va a hacer que
nosotros vayamos a buscar nuevos los
nuevos recursos para seguir aprendiendo
hoy en día podemos agarrar un libro
podemos ver vídeos en youtube aprender
como aquí ya vamos incluso aprender cómo
mandar cohetes salud
este es un examen que no es muy bueno
entonces te puedan dar la calificación
es un 65 este
es reprobatoria en cualquier parte del
mundo no
sin embargo este examen pertenece una
persona que hizo algo muy peculiar
esta calificación reprobatoria cuando
esta persona a la nasa
esta persona tuvo la oportunidad de ser
un impacto fue en este mundo el impacto
en el planeta
el paso al desarrollo de nuevas
tecnologías
y de hecho esta persona se encuentra en
esta victoria hasta aquí
esta persona soy yo
este examen no probatorio no significa
nada para nosotros de nosotros un paso
más en nuestra carrera
es el impulso a seguir adaptando
podemos dejar que un paradigma de ser no
bueno en matemáticas se vaya los grandes
sueños
como mencioné antes diferentes pilares
en los cuales podemos basarnos utilice
los tres para seguir adelante
si hubiera quedado con ese 65 mi sueño
sería otro
pero mi determinación en la curiosidad
seguir aprendiendo me llevo a lograr
hacer un pacto
otra historia bien ha pasado se hubiera
quedado con la crecida después del con
inteligencia general y la disciplina
dice tercer claro es básico es esencial
debemos seguir aprendiendo debemos
seguir preguntando acerca por qué pasan
las cosas
debemos seguir rompiendo paradigmas
debemos seguir uniendo fronteras
y debemos seguir sigo con estos años